بينما يحارب العالم جائحة فيروس كورونا الجديد ، يقوم الرئيس الأمريكي دونالد ترامب ورئيس الوزراء الياباني شينزو آبي بالترويج للعلاجات الممكنة ، يروج ترامب لعقار الملاريا هيدروكسي كلوروكين على الرغم من الأدلة الضعيفة على أنه فعال بالفعل ضد الفيروس ، ما الذي يجب أن تخسره سأقول إنهما سيحصلان عليه ما الذي يجب أن تخسره مقابل عقار مضاد للإنفلونزا بدأ اسم العلامة التجارية اليابانية لـ fav يظهر Revere من إنتاج Fujifilm هل حصلت على لا ، سنضاعف المخزون الحالي من نبات نباتي ثلاث مرات ونوسع الاستخدام لمليوني شخص كما يقول يشير الباحثون إلى الاختلافات الرئيسية بين الأقراص التي يروج لها الرئيس ترامب ورئيس الوزراء آبي ، وهو ما يفعله شينزو آبي في الحصول على أي شيء مختلف عما يفعله الرئيس ترامب بشكل مختلف قليلاً عن سجل الدبوس الموجود منذ فترة طويلة وعلى عكس الهيدروكسي كلوروكين. تم استخدامه لاختبار فعاليته ، تظهر تقارير فيروسات أخرى في الصين أن المراجع الأقران كان فعالًا في علاج الكارب  ronavirus لكن البحث
محدود ، تجري تجارب سريرية في
اليابان ومن المقرر أن تبدأ في الولايات المتحدة.تخطط اليابان
لتوفير الدواء مجانًا إلى 20
دولة ، وهناك
آثار جانبية خطيرة محتملة بما في ذلك
العيوب الخلقية إذا كان شخص ما مصابًا بفيروس كورونا ،
فهل توصي بتناول هذا الدواء
اسمحوا لي أن أقتل الناس في القرن التاسع عشر ،
فماذا
تختار هيدروكسي كلوروكين يمكن أن يكون له أيضًا
آثار جانبية خطيرة مثل مشاكل
القلب وأنا أضر الباحثين في جميع أنحاء
العالم باختبار جميع أنواع الأدوية
التي قد تكون الأمل الوحيد حتى
يتم تطوير لقاح  إذا تم تطوير لقاح ، يمكن
للمرضى الخاضعين للحجر الصحي
المعزولين في منازلهم محاربة
الشعور بالوحدة واليأس ، فأنت تشعر
بالاكتئاب حقًا ، فإن شقة chika Mia takis في طوكيو
مليئة بالإمدادات ، وعليها
الانتظار لمدة تصل إلى 10 أيام للحصول على نتائج اختبار فيروس كورونا الخاصة بها
.  قم
بإعداد أي نوع من نظام الكمبيوتر
على الرغم من أن نتيجة الاختبار
ستظهر لاحقًا ، لذا لا ترسل ذلك بالبريد الإلكتروني  يجعلني أشعر
بالقلق حقًا والحصول على نتيجة الاختبار في
أقرب وقت ممكن ، إنها أكثر
أهمية من التركيز على استخدام
العداد في هذه المرحلة. تتساءل لماذا
تركز حكومتها على دواء غير مثبت
بدلاً من تسريع
عملية الاختبار للمرضى في طي النسيان؟
سي إن إن طوكيو ،
هذه هي آخر صورة لفو فيديريتشي
يمزح أنه كان سجينًا في الحجر الصحي
، توفي في 27 مارس من
فيروس كورونا شيرا أحضرت البقالة
لأنه لم يستطع الخروج لأن
ابنته روبرتا تركتها خارج
الباب كما قال  وداعًا من النافذة
التي كانت آخر مرة رأيت فيها والدي
جالسًا على البحر في نفس اليوم الذي
مات فيه والدها توفي عم والد روبرتا
داليو في المنزل ، وهو محارب قديم في
Carabinieri في يوم الشرطة شبه العسكرية الإيطالية ،
كان ليو يعاني من أعراض فيروس كورونا
والالتهاب الرئوي والحمى المرتفعة بسبب
لم يتم إدخاله إلى المستشفى أو اختباره ،
لكن لم يتم تضمينه في عدد الوفيات الناجمة عن فيروس كورونا ،
وتوفي عمه ماريو في
الأسبوع السابق في تمريض ح.
يعتقد أوم روبرتا أن السبب ربما كان
فيروس كورونا دور رعاية المسنين في
شمال إيطاليا شهدت الشهر الماضي ارتفاعًا مفاجئًا
في الوفيات.عانت إيطاليا من
أعلى حصيلة وفيات في العالم بسبب
الفيروس ، لكن العدد الفعلي لوفيات كوفين 19
قد يكون أعلى بكثير في
وقت مبكر.  رؤساء البلديات في شمال إيطاليا
حيث تضرر الفيروس بشدة منذ أن كانت البيانات
في حالة من الفوضى منذ البداية ، أدركنا أن
شيئًا ما كان يحدث
لم ينعكس في البيانات الرسمية ،
كما يقول كلوديو كونش لو عمدة بلدة صغيرة
نيم وإخوانه ، عمدة المنطقة المجاورة
لاحظت مدينة بيرغامو جيورجو جوري
نفس المخالفات التي تلقيتها من
البيانات ورأيت أن القتلى كانوا أكثر
بكثير من أولئك الذين أصيبوا بالعدوى ، ويقول
إنه اتصل برئيس بلدية آخر أكد
شكوكه في أن عدد الوفيات
كان أعلى بكثير من نفس الفترة
الماضية  في العام على الرغم من أن الغالبية العظمى من
الوفيات هذا العام لم تُنسب إلى فيروس كورونا ،
صحافي بيرغامو في SIA في Vernet Z ،
حقق أيضًا في الشذوذ الذي  كان من الواضح
أن نرى في صفحات النعي في
جريدته صدى دي بيرغامو ، وعادة
ما ننشر صفحة واحدة من النعي
كحد أقصى يخبرني بها ولكن الشهر الماضي
شهدنا ارتفاعًا مفاجئًا مع ما يصل إلى 13
صفحة في اليوم من
الوفيات بسبب فيروس كورونا في الغرور و
وخلص آخرون إلى أنه على الأقل ضعف ما
تم الإبلاغ عنه ، قال مسؤولو وزارة الصحة
لشبكة CNN ، إن الأولوية الآن هي
التعامل مع الأزمة ، لكنهم في
النهاية يأملون في التوصل إلى
تقرير أكثر دقة ، منتصر حزب
أوكا بيرتا الذي فقد أباً ،
واثنين من أعمامه يفهم السلطات
غارقة هنا في بيرغامو ، كان الأمر
مثل تسونامي ، تقول إن هذا الطابق
قد تعرض بابا للقصف في بوتينزا ربما كان
يدفع ثمن وهم القدرة المطلقة
عندما سمعنا لأول مرة عن المرض الذي
اعتقدنا أننا سنتغلب عليه بأننا
كنا أقوى لكنها معركة صعبة و
إنه فيروس كورونا أقوى منا ،
وبغض النظر عن الأرقام الفعلية ، فإن
إيطاليا تدفع ثمناً باهظاً للغاية بن ويدمان
سي إن إن روما ،
أيها
الجحيم  هذا ذهب من روسيا ،
سأتحدث إليكم من مومباي ،
ماهاراشترا ، مرحبًا بكم من بكين
لمدة 21 يومًا ، لقد كنت في الحجر الصحي في
الإكوادور بسبب خليج كوف في 19
استراحة
[موسيقى]
يبدو الأمر كما لو أن الحياة معلقة الآن ولكننا
لم يتم إعطاؤهم الأدوات اللازمة لمعرفة كيفية
التعامل مع هذا الأمر ، مما أدى إلى تعليق حياتنا
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فقد كانت رسالة معتادة من
حكومتنا يجب عليهم توجيهها بشأن
منزل الولاية.
الشهر الماضي أو نحو ذلك ،
لا يمكننا حقًا مغادرة منازلنا باستثناء
شراء الطعام والإمدادات الطبية أو
المشي لمسافة قصيرة.
الابتعاد أسهل قليلاً ،
هذا مكتبي حيث لا يمكنك رؤية
أي مكياج ولا إطار وتعب. أنا من
إيطاليا وأعيش معك ،
وسنتعامل في غضون أيام قليلة ، لذا دعني أقدم لك
بعض النصائح ، من الصعب جدًا عليك
الناس ليتم حبسهم  مكان واحد
لفترات طويلة من الوقت ، كنت أنا نفسي
أركز على اللياقة البدنية ، لقد
تم تدريب أختي في لورد ، وهي أداة ما
زلنا نحضر خدمات الكنيسة أيام الأحد من
خلال الإنترنت ، خذ طريقة القهوة
بشكل أفضل إذا كنت تعرف أنها إيطالية
اشتركت في بعض  تنسى الدورات التدريبية عبر الإنترنت
ملابسهم فقط كما ترى وقم
فقط بتجربة منزلك ، لذا ربما
لم تتح لك الفرصة لتجربة
أحد الأشياء التي بدأت في القيام بها لمدة
خمس دقائق فقط بين المكالمات الهاتفية
ورسائل البريد الإلكتروني القادمة للخارج
والقفز على الترامبولين ،
إنه لأمر مدهش ما يفعله القليل
من الارتداد لمساعدتك على الشعور
بتحسن قليل عن نفسك بطريقة
لن تصدق أبدًا أنني مزيفة لقد
أطعمت أن كل شيء بمحفظة
سيخرج  المزيد قال
مع بعضنا البعض وخاصة عبر
كوكبنا كل ما يمكنني قوله هو أننا يجب أن
نكون إيجابيين
أرى البطانة الفضية في هذا النادي
متأكد من أننا جميعًا ننتظر هذه المعركة
وسوف نتغلب على الوضع.  مجرد البقاء في
المنزل والبقاء آمنين ، أعتقد أنه عندما تكون الحالة
جيدة جدًا وأتمنى أن يظل الجميع
آمنين وصحيين وأن يكونوا إيجابيين كثيرًا
من روسيا ، يبدو الأمر وكأن الناس
يتعرفون حتى لو لم يتمكنوا من رؤية بعضهم
البعض ، يبدو الأمر وكأننا
سنشارك  أغلى شيء
لدينا وحان الوقت وهو أيضًا الشيء الوحيد
الذي لدينا الآن